christmas is upon us people how you
doing Greg Alva here John here and what
better Christmas present from the
youtubes than art sphere entertainments
released in a super showdown ball toon
sandwiches back people I love these
segments guys if you haven't subscribed
to arts peer entertainment you got to do
that as soon as possible seriously if
you haven't seen like the super villain
bowl superhero Bowl and like countless
other videos or trailers boost they are
brilliant people love what they do let's
watch this
[Music]
I see just a couple who haven't put a
uniform on yet who get them in here
immediately Kurt we do not have time for
this hey naked nobody wants to see you
naked
[Music]
Austin regenerates us at the end of each
battle with no memories preceding events
like worst world exactly like this one
does this mean we are all actually
robots
[Music]
I nominate Skywalker don't kid you know
me so why's this how did we break this
that's the most frequent winner of the
superhero balls
I had the truth it has taken years of
practice but I taught myself to retain
my memories through my regenerations
with my powers of precognition or saw a
chain of events that the leaders to this
moment
before the conclusion of the last
superhero bath I can edit supersite as a
decoration covertly restructure my super
side after which I was able to teleport
between the cells until I found what
nice warrior were you I don't have time
to explain in a few days you will be
forced to battle in an arena unless you
do as I say you will lose remember these
words her powers unbeatable but it
wasn't always those power powers talking
about when the time comes so mad watch
me I spent the next few days partying
around myself altering reality to keep
myself entertained I told you I was
entertained speaking of which you trick
me man that's doctor man well now that
we're all weak why don't you just beam
us out of here the arena is enclosed in
an invisible barrier that our powers are
unable to penetrate
the power your emanates from Oscar and
South destroy Moscow
we free the chimp is correct I think we
need to address the Godzilla in the room
which is the fact that Godzilla is in
the room I'm gonna keep checking you
never find what you're looking for in
the first 15 million it's gonna take an
army it's gonna take all working with
he's deployed of my existence how about
I bend it in your face I'm not working
with him he killed my parents
it's better than him being your parent
better than your parent killing you
adoptive parent it's better than the
parent being killed by the child we have
to make a choice we can continue to
fight each other kill each other die so
covert or we can find him
just this once
[Music]
what does your whiteboard look like show
me what you got it's so much more
pressure when it's a still allowing
[Music]
now huh much as I hate disappointing the
people at home what are you doing huh I
can't fight you why and why not it's
because I'm a girl then you again - the
pool of course not it's because I dig
you and I just can't bury someone I dig
what I think we may actually be soul
mates
okay well though I'm not sure why you'd
have to trick me and honour to win from
the footage I've seen you're pretty much
invincible not entirely and leave me if
you hit me with that bat
you'd win hands down because you see I
can repair any part of me - Briggs it's
true definitely I just have a sense
apart
oh yeah all of these Disney products
gods oh my god
oh my god
yep to get some alone time in this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's a villain
my favorite don't be fooled they're all
the same flavor
[Music]
mom what
Oh No whoa
[Music]
Oh
Oh Oh
[Music]
[Music]
it's an honor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
like a team like a league
[Music]
Oh God Oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
well yeah hardly you oh please you can
yes
I can handle this - his younger self Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
- time what trouble Ford's in real time
see I started talking to you five
seconds ago and now I'm here
[Music]
but help us grow the random time
travelers you're our only hope
[Music]
I'm gonna look at my best factually
correct yeah according to the time
circles we jumped back 80 years the
start of the Oscars
[Music]
we first King Kong
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's not cool to make another man's
private vehicle okay oh sorry doc we'll
be doing in a previous superhero who
travels through time without contingency
plutonium how do we get him to channel
that energy into the next Bachelor I'll
be wait are you going
[Music]
sacrificed himself
no I can't yes let's get somewhere less
conspicuous okay how do we get close
enough to Oscar to witness this
miraculous Lygia I'm a friend there's
nothing I knew that gingernut was poor
but who lends some party air not him my
other friend ability collectable if a
cane falls in an arena and no one's
around to see it does it really fool
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I know you did send us back to the
past but we're back we're back from the
past and we know his weakness it's gold
elementary my dear so we buy him off
with gold and he lets us go no you idiot
Jared is what hurts him so he's
vulnerable to a single element that's
native to a different planet but still
happens to be here that's weird
yes super weird
[Music]
I've been playing around with Oh No so
we just need to be the Oscar in order to
kill you does that ring any bells ring
oh no the hardest cake and ate it
she's been consumed by the power of the
Ring relationship strongly seconded the
room I'm gonna respect myself I'm gonna
stop breaking things and start building
them I'm gonna wait jeans
[Music]
I feel like my life is just beginning
no Harley
I'll never let go
[Music]
so what gives me laser arm removal
[Music]
no come on down at my hand just one
person the power you've accumulated is
too much for any one being given our
current enormity that's actually the
size of a normal finally you know you
can't destroy me I'm just a big blue
bully with a body I didn't earn
[Music]
don't you mean dr. Oh the most horrific
thing I've ever seen John you can't eat
your pain Watchmen season 2 now know
what's gonna happen
[Music]
well what about snoke's origin story oh
[Music]
I killed them all No
[Music]
Oh No
[Applause]
[Music]
I got it
good
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
reach
[Music]
No
[Music]
go yeah buddy
[Music]
[Music]
all those movies you studied for so many
years
[Music]
0o oh no this can't be this final and
the Oscar goes to
[Music]
are we on the left
how can we claim to 1 given how many
were lost
well there's one more he can afford to
lose no wait raiga you know what to do
oh wow that's a much better idea than
what I was thinking
[Music]
it was worth a shot
[Music]
that
[Music]
everyone just came back
[Music]
I'm just happy here I got this close
friend ah it doesn't make one turn
invisible but in your case that's a big
check in the plus column I don't think
we're quite ready for that just yet
trust me I'm dated worse okay here goes
Oh see I knew it was too soon okay look
I've been researching this experimental
surgery in China yeah beautiful
yes interesting we do we go
I certainly don't want to stick around
here it's always humans are an
extraordinary species heck they created
all of us but one superhuman was offered
into me hundreds of them all at once I
feel it suffer superhuman fatigue and
turn on us well I don't know I can make
us a world I am sort of a plant planet
wait your dad is a planet hurry hey look
I'm familiar with living in the shadow
of a parent button that is really
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Asia gets my vote awesome taser it is I
don't know what it means but I like it
I'll start building it as soon as we get
there everyone can have input it would
be the first planet designed by
committee
okay everyone brace yourselves
[Music]
much more to choose from I guess there's
only so many kind of just wanna be
nothing home or whatever
[Music]
this is the end this can't be the end
this cannot be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
22 I'm sorry yeah exploiting the
intellectual properties of other people
always brings a huge smile to my face
[Music]
damn they have brought this to life that
a cartoons look like I mean they're the
actual ones yeah I know right it's crazy
that's what I mean they are professional
animators
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
murder your friends oh I thought we were
gonna see the cereal mascot damn it oh
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I find a really impressive how you can
just sort of hop into it at any moment
between superhero supervillain and the
super showdown bowl you kind of come in
at any moment whichever one it does work
best to start from superhero Bowl and
make your way here especially the
jumping off point with Deadpool the
Oscar villain and stuff that that was
teased at the end of the last one but
this just blew my mind away like you
might talk about fanservice this is kind
of fanservice hunting school so much
inventiveness throughout because it
starts off and I love the structure that
they did with them they're all gathered
together they're in the holding cell or
whatever that meant hadn't brought them
in and then they're doing their fight in
the arena and I like when they'd go to
the Time Traveler's in the DeLorean and
you get all the different members they
could please like cast players who have
all done time-traveling before you come
back you settle the score and then like
that 22 Jump Street kind of ending or
you're doing the different styles that
they can do it's like I would love to
see the super cartoon or super anime but
like any one of those would be great
when they when they did this serial when
I was like ah are we gonna see like the
Methow the thing I've always wanted to
see you know honey like Captain Crunch
versus Count Chocula versus
and for real I mean it was a funny joke
that'd be cool for them to do one day no
seriously for two people who put this
together
I can't imagine just what the
structuring must be like on this and
what the writing process must be on it
because yeah they rely heavily for their
jokes to be you know one-liners puns a
lot of times like some character says
one Jew says one line in there that
leads it to a pun to some other random
character like a sight gag or something
like that yeah and I like the their
attention to detail on how they have
this sort of connective tissue this
actor played this character or that
actor played that character as well
that's what I thought when you saw
Apocalypse thee might see Poe Dameron or
something like that all the Alan Rickman
all the similarities to with certain
characters like we were talking about
the evil fathers killing their fathers
all these moments were just so well
thought out is you have to really script
this incredibly well like really
structure the hell out of this before
he's hurting and then there's the
process of the driving and the animation
and everything which is always such a
delight I found myself really paying
attention to the background this time
and so many sequences cuz you you
constantly have like a gold Agent Smith
cloning himself and then fighting some
other character in the background I love
this one this was seriously incredible
it's weird it's kind of like a
culmination year for so many themes from
Star Wars the end game this feels like
the culmination of the two of the tunes
sandwich bowls it's incredible seriously
what a way to go out and I hope this
becomes number one on trending as soon
as possible because these guys have come
such a long way super super proud of
them and they're gonna I can't wait for
them like make a film or something one
day because this is incredible oh yeah
and I mean I really loved seeing the
little snippet they showed at the end
like I would watch a whole featurette of
just them showing the process of how
they break everything down because they
are so intricate and there are so many
characters and you start to wonder okay
like what made you decide on all these
specific I mean they cover such a broad
spectrum but you know certain characters
probably got left out to see more of the
behind the scenes would be so awesome
because yeah this has grown and taken on
a life of its own and it's the perfect
little Christmas present and off the
year I hope we get some of these other
ones they tease dead or or at least
something that continues this
you know you know story that they've set
up here cuz yeah it was just such a fun
world and such a fun way to actually
celebrate all the pop culture that's
come in the past you know several years
there are lots of things to argue and
debate about and this takes them all and
matches them together in such a fun and
whimsical way that I think everybody can
kind of hop on board and enjoy and then
a time where fandom is so galvanized and
so kind of reactionary in a lot of ways
I think this is something that's just
sort of goodwill to everybody they take
these looks at these iconic characters
and they seem to really for the most we
can't like have everyone have a line of
dialogue but for the most part they seem
to have a good understanding of the the
basis the nucleus of these characters
they're so iconic and in like current
pop culture but then even to do the
time-traveling and go back you know with
the Oscar villain and then to go back in
time to the original iconic players and
have like the old classic movie
characters and stuff yeah that was
brilliant I love what they did with the
Oscar villain is this character that
adapts every kind of abilities sort of
like the center that you see the
sentinels and in here at one point or
one of them but he's sort of like the
Sentinels from the x-men days of future
past movie just having every single
ability which I thought was just this
whole thing was just so clever I
remember when we first saw a superhero
bold and like they had nowhere near as
many subs as they do now
oh yeah and they've come such a long way
and I can't wait to see what they do and
bigger mediums down the road get him a
movie or a TV series this has such a
blend of great spoof and parody but also
at times just being genuinely really
cool and then also exploring like random
idea that I go but actually like you
know like with Deadpool and Harley Quinn
that relationship oh yeah actually they
would be a good fit now that I think
about it the movie versions of them with
Watchmen with dr. Manhattan getting fat
I love that yeah just finished with
Watchmen season one which by the way is
a brilliant show it'd be pretty funny
you know they had fat Thor be funny to
see like fat hat didn't thank you great
guys subscribe arts for your
entertainment as soon as you can thank
you guys for putting this together this
is such a delight can't wait to see you
guys do in the future subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell we'll catch you guys soon
merry Christmas to all we'll be having a
few days off
got some videos pre-recorded pre-edited
to go up be back on friday to cover the
mandalorian see you guys